The Game of Thrones season 6 trailer is finally
out, and combined with a bunch of promo stills
and hints from the books, we can predict a
lot of the big events of the upcoming season
– so let’s have a look.
The trailer starts at the Wall, with the body
of Jon Snow, who is stabbed to death by his
fellow Night’s Watchmen at the end of the
last season and book.
It looks like there’s a conflict over Jon’s
corpse – Davos uses Jon’s sword to fight
some Night’s Watchmen, and we see some Watchmen
trying to break through a locked door.
We also see the red witch Melisandre lurking
around, and talking to Davos.
It looks like the Watchmen are trying to stop
Mel doing something to Jon's body – probably
some magic that will lead to Jon's resurrection.
There are heaps of hints for Jon's return
in the books and the show, and it's believed
that Jon's direwolf Ghost might be involved
– so it’s telling that we see the wolf
by Jon’s side in the trailer.
Later we see a battle known as Bastardbowl
beginning, between the Boltons on one side,
and the other northmen, with wildlings down
from the Wall, on the other.
Tormund is there, Ramsay is probably there,
and we even see someone who looks suspiciously
like Jon.
Also near Winterfell, we see Sansa and Theon
fleeing from the Boltons, and it looks like
they get caught by a Bolton man with dogs,
but then Brienne appears, kills the man, and
presumably saves them.
Sansa later looks like she’s in a safe situation,
maybe with Brienne or the northmen, though
Littlefinger looks like he’s lurking up
there too, so she might end up with him.
Point is, Sansa, Theon, Brienne and Littlefinger
may also get caught up in this massive battle.
There’ll certainly be deaths – maybe Tormund,
hopefully Ramsay – though it looks like
he’s got at least 20 good men here, so he’s
probably unstoppable.
Anyway in Bravos, we see that Arya is still
blind, and spends some time begging as Blind
Beth.
She’s still at the House of Black and White,
though she seems to have a falling out with
her magical assassin friends the Faceless
Men – one of them, the Waif, hits her, and
we later see Arya leaping off a rooftop – maybe
running away from the Waif.
This might indicate that Arya leaves the Faceless
Men, maybe returning to Westeros where she
has some unfinished business.
Further east, the city of Meereeis left in
the hands of a dwarf, an ex-slave, and two
eunuchs, which sounds like the start to some
terrible joke.
There’s a shot of an explosion at the Great
Pyramid, which maybe could be caused by the
Sons of the Harpy, who continue to resist
Dany’s rule.
We also see Tyrion in some dark underground
location, which could be the Pyramid basement
where two of Dany’s dragons are locked up.
Maybe this is how the dragons get released…
While Tyrion and co.
try to keep things under control in Meereen,
Daario and Jorah head off to look for Dany,
who was last seen flying out of the city on
Drogon’s back.
One of Jorah’s fingernails has visibly gone
black, which indicates the spread of the nasty
disease Jorah caught from the stone men in
Valyria.
It’ll be interesting to see if anyone finds
out about his condition, which is both deadly,
and contagious.
Anyway, it looks like Dany is captured by
Dothraki, and we see her being taken what
looks like Vaes Dothrak, a sort of a sacred
city to the Dothraki.
So things might look bad for Dany, but she’s
got a Drogon ex machina coming her way, so
she’ll probably be okay.
By the time Jorah and Daario find her, she’ll
have made a bloody barbeque of her Dothraki
captors.
Back in Westeros, we see a new player arrive
at the Iron Islands.
A ship sails in on a stormy sea, bringing
in the infamous pirate Euron Greyjoy , who
for some reason doesn’t have an eyepatch,
despite being, you know, the “Crow’s Eye”,
the quintessential badass pirate king, but
anyway.
We see Euron standing on a bridge in a storm
which is probably where he kills his brother
Balon, which leads to the Kingsmoot, an election
of sorts where the ironborn choose their new
King.
This could be a really cool scene, with Aeron
Damphair, Yara or Asha Greyjoy, and the Crow’s
Eye, duking it out, though sadly there’s
apparently no Victarion.
In King’s Landing, Jaime has an awkward
sort of a ‘honey, I’m home’ moment,
bringing the body of Mycrella back to Cersei.
In the books, Jaime and Cersei are pretty
well broken up at this point, but here, they
catch up on some incest, and Jaime promises
to help her win back her power.
Their enemies are the Faith – the High Sparrow
and his followers, who seem determined to
bring down the Lannisters – "bring down
an empire".
The faith seems to still have Margaery imprisoned,
and it looks like the Tyrells try to get her
back.
The wildcard in this conflict is Robert Strong,
the reanimated Gregor Clegane made by Qyburn
to serve Cersei.
As an eight-foot tall monsterous zombie Mountain,
we can be pretty certain that Bobby Strong
will wreck shit up this season – “I choose
violence”.
But if rumours prove true, the silent giant
might be stopped by his brother the Hound,
returned from the grave.
At the end of the trailer, we see Bran standing
in the snow, turning around and seeing the
Night King, the apparent leader of the white
walkers.
This isn’t actually happening for realises,
it’s a sort of a vision – remember, Bran
is hanging out with this creepy old tree-man
called the “three-eyed crow” a.k.a.
Brynden Rivers a.k.a.
“Bloodraven”, who's recently been recast,
and who’s teaching him to use the magic
of the old gods, which involves seeing through
the eyes of weirwood trees across long distances
and even back in time.
Bran uses this magic to have visions of the
present and the past, and so this thing with
the white walkers looks like one of those.
What’s really exciting though, are these
shots of what looks to be the fight at the
Tower of Joy, an event that books readers
have been obsessing over for literally twenty
years, ever since the first book came out.
This is something that happened towards the
end of Robert’s Rebellion, a epic fight
with a young Eddard Stark and six of his men
against three famous Kingsguard knights, including
the legendary Arthur Dayne.
But more important than the fight is its aftermath,
where Eddard makes a promise to his dying
sister Lyanna – which is believed to relate
to birth of Jon Snow.
This scene could lead to the reveal of one
of the biggest, oldest secrets in Game of
Thrones – the true parentage of Jon Snow
– R+L=J.
So that’s the trailer.
You got the resurrection of Jon Snow, your
Bastardbowl, Arya going rogue, and conflict
in Meereen.
You got your Dothraki BBQ, your Kingsmoot,
possibly Cleganebowl, and finally, after all
these years, the Tower of Joy.
This season looks like it's gonna be great,
so make sure to subscribe for more explanations
and analysis throughout the series.
We’ve already got videos out on Arya’s
character arc, Dany’s future path, greyscale,
Euron Greyjoy, Robert Strong, the return of
the Hound, R+L=J, Jon's resurrection, and
much more, so check those out if you’re
keen, and expect many more videos throughout
Season 6 and beyond.
Thank you for watching, and many thanks to
all the Patrons supporting this channel, including
Anissa Aponte, benny Vasquez, Lamal Ronso,
Madisyn Ritland, amy mcdermott, Julio Storch,
Lesley Ann Davis, Nahir, Wouter van Straalen,
JV, Justin Woolhandler, Sondre Benjamin Aasen,
Seth Topps, Twop3nny, bluemargaritas, Cynethryth,
Einstein Snow, Henry Cooper, and DICK JOHNSON.
Thanks again, and see you next time.